[موسيقى]
الشهر الرابع من شهور السنه الميلاديه
يسمى بابريل وهو احد الاربعه شهور الذي
يتكون من 30 يوما يسمى بالعراق وبلاد شام
بنيسان وهي كلمه سومريه تعني الباكوره اي
انه ياتي في باكوره الربيع وما اعتقهر
الزمن اصبح ياتي في عز الربيع ويتزامن ذلك
مع موسم صياح النبات وابريل كلمه مشتقه من
اللاتينيه
والتي تعني التفتح فهو موسم تتفتح فيه
جميع انواع النباتات ومطره منبت للربيع
الصيفي وهل الاولين الله يرحمهم بالشام
يقولون مطرت نيسان بتحيا الارض
والانسان
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
والامطار ساقطه في شهر ابريل يسميها اهل
الخليج بس الرايات والحجاز بالروايح واهل
نجد بلراويح والباديه يسمونها بسماك نسبه
الى نجيب اسماك لا تسقني ماء الحياه بذله
بل فسقني بالعزي كاس الحنظلي ان كنت في
عدد العبيد فهمتي فوق الثريا والسماك
الاعزلي
[موسيقى]